almost three and a half decades have
passed since the murder of daniel morgan
outside an ordinary pub in southeast
london
but this is a far from ordinary case at
his heart allegations of police
corruption
of criminal networks collusion with
tabloid journalists
and a family whose fight for answers has
been frustrated
at every turn i've had enough of them
i've had enough in british policing to
be quite honest you know after
after 34 years of it aleister morgan
knows it's now highly unlikely anyone
will ever be brought to justice for his
brother's murder
but an independent report he hopes may
finally shed some light on a case
that continues to be a stain on the
reputation of britain's biggest police
force
i'm hoping that i will be vindicated
in fact i believe i will be vindicated
the fact that daniel was expressing
repeatedly in the weeks and months and
days before his death concern over
police corruption and then
bang he's dead you know
it it just looks so awful
a private investigator daniel morgan's
job often required him to delve into the
seedier side of london life
[Music]
he'd been here in the golden lion pub in
sydney on the night of march the 10th
1987 for a meeting with his business
partner
it was the last time he was seen alive
we'll probably never know what daniel
morgan discussed inside this pub
shortly before his murder was he as some
have suggested
about to expose local police corruption
whatever the motive even scotland yard
admits the initial investigation into
his death
was hampered by corrupt officers
daniel morgan was attacked as he left to
collect his vehicle from the pub
car park lying in wait his killer
embedded an axe in the back of his head
the 1987 murder investigation was
bungled from the outset daniel morgan's
business partner jonathan reese
and one of the investigating officers
detective sergeant sid fillery
were among six people arrested but later
released without charge
over the years police launched another
five failed investigations
culminating in the dramatic collapse of
a case in 2011
against five men again including
jonathan recent said villarry
to this day they deny any involvement in
daniel morgan's death
and successfully sued the metropolitan
police after the collapse of the trial
the case took another twist when the now
defunct news of the world
placed the lead scotland yard
investigator under surveillance
after he made a fresh appeal to solve
the murder on the bbc's crime watch
program
he and his wife jackie hames a fellow
serving officer at the time
and presenter on crime watch received
anonymous death threats
she still remembers the shock of seeing
people in a van
watching their house it was later
stopped by police
those inside news of the world employees
i can still visualize it to this day the
wind the driver's door window
um came down and i saw something
metal being raised and i just went into
sheer panic i just felt so under threat
and so terrified that i just had to
leave the house
jackie hayes never believed the paper's
assertion that it was investigating
allegations she was having an affair
with chief superintendent david cook the
couple had in fact been
married for years it's her hope and that
of aleister morgan that alleged links
between the tabloid
corrupt police and organized crime will
be fully uncovered
in this long-awaited independent report
but the morgan family have been here
many times before
in their search for the truth over
daniel's murder
mark white sky news